I'm Sam shank and I'm CEO and co-founder
I try and keep everything nice and clear
for Justin to do great coding yeah I'm
the Justin chilton the Android lead at
hotel tonight I am responsible for
building the phone app the tablet app I
manage our Android team and interact
with our design team and our various
teams to make sure that the Android app
is beautiful and working perfectly this
is my third online travel startup and
the idea for hotel tonight started when
I was doing the second one I found out I
was like on my mobile phone more than I
was on my computer at home and I said
why isn't there a good way to book a
hotel on your smartphone and so I
thought about what the mobile use case
is and it's about last minute and it's
about booking in the moment and so we
came up with hotel tonight when i
started at hotel tonight in February of
2012 and I think there were something
like four hundred thousand downloads at
that point I think we're at around 1.6
million now so we've seen obviously
explosive growth in the last year we've
also completely redesigned the app
really since we've implemented things
like the action bar and the fragments
and really adhered to to a lot of the
Google design guidelines we've seen that
growth certainly exponentially yeah we'd
see an exponential growth releases this
is really adhering to a lot of those
good practices so with Android it was
just a matter of time until we had the
resources to be able to invest in that
the tablet support we're really pleased
with the result both in the performance
of it as well as the uptake from our
users as you can see just right here
we've got our market list it lists the
various markets in which we sell hotels
you can see we've got these big
beautiful photos in a grid we've got a
country selector here that quickly
allows folks to jump to a particular
country and see inventory in that
country and as I mentioned we also use
the drawer pattern here so this is
something that I actually took from last
year's google i/o this sliding drawer
pattern is very slick and so we stole
that and we're you can tell that we're
using the action bar paradigm here as
well and let's actually just scroll down
to San Francisco here I think we've got
some some inventory San Francisco will
list a kind of a similar grid interface
and again we're using fragments here
that allow us to very easily modify
things like
layouts in fact one of my favorite
features is we we recently implemented
expandable notifications with the
ability to like or dislike a hotel so
it's just a very quick action after
you've stayed at a hotel the next day at
two o'clock you'll receive a an
expandable notification that just
quickly asks did you like the hotel did
you not like the hotel and aplomb
tapping on that notification you have
the opportunity to actually add some
additional comments that's an optional
step but that's that's a really slick
feature and it definitely improved our
conversion rate on on getting those
reviews from customers because it's just
so fast and easy for them so we've got
again leveraging these these big
beautiful photos for the hotels I think
the photos are one of the features that
our customers like like most about the
app so we've got these really rich
really nice photos of the room of the
lobby of the bar very often and so folks
tend to really enjoy these these big
photos and we leverage this on both the
phone and the tablet app we've also
implemented this this great new map
using the new maps v2 API and this map
has some great features like the ability
to tilt the ability to rotate and in
fact once we get to a particular zoom
level we'll even see like a 3d rendering
of the buildings so that's that's been a
really fun feature on the phone so since
launching our tablet app a couple of
months ago we've actually seen some
enormous growth we greater than fifty
percent of our recent growth since
launching the app is actually come from
from tablets and our fourth most
frequently used device now is actually
the Nexus 7 device so that that's been
great we you know we're seeing a lot of
a lot of momentum in the tablet market
obviously and we wanted to stay ahead of
the bell curve technically and really
build an app that worked great on all
devices and especially some of the newer
nicer tablets like the Nexus 7 in the
Nexus 10 oh really excited about what's
next for Android Justin and his team
have some really exciting things coming
next that we can't tell you about now
but stay tuned and in the meantime get
the free hotel tonight app and hope you
guys find a way to book a hotel tonight
soon